good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everyone congratulations a huge mazel
tov on making it to the end of the week
without losing your mind yes and i just
have so many personal updates to share
that i'm just going to jump right into
them because
in so many ways i'm a different person
than i was on the show yesterday i hear
that
completely and in in no order of
importance
three major things happened in my life
yesterday one
i moved it has just been such an
exciting treacherous experience
but made less treacherous with the most
wonderful moving company roadway okay by
the way i use them for my move two years
ago we use them for our studio move like
we everyone in our family uses them
they are true and by the way i've had
the same movers every time they're like
the nicest guys
it is the best company it's the best
company it's the best moving experience
i feel like i used to dread moving so
much but they really make it as
pleasant as humans they do it all they
do it all they've even given me a
discount code to share with the toasters
it's jackie 10. if you want to get five
percent off
long distance moves or 10 off local
moves
head to roadway have a link in my
stories use code jackie10 and get some
money off your next move and start
moving and grooving start moving and
grooving you
moving like into this palatial you know
palace in the sky
has really got me i've inspired you all
bent out of shape and there actually
is uh identical unit in your building
like
how many like four floors up yeah um and
i'm i'm actually
i think you should take it i'm actually
really thinking about it i just love my
building so much i know
i love my building and if you moved into
my building like
one theo and bruno best friends i know
they would never spend a day apart i
know like that's that's big you gotta
it's like
you gotta it's like you just gotta do it
for your kids you know yeah you have to
do it for the kids two like you and i
could be like podcasting all the time
like
just running up and down and like
creating content no i know three
like ben and zach could be playing
monopoly all day long yeah and then like
i'm i really
i dread being alone it's like one of my
biggest fears which is why like i'm a
homebody and therefore ben has to be a
homebody
but like a building body if you but not
only that like if you lived in my
building or i lived in your building
like ben could go do whatever he want
and then like we could just like watch
tv together
no i know i really think you should at
least look at the unit yeah no
i am it's so funny like buildings in new
york are so snotty i actually reached
out yesterday like after you
sent me the link and i'm like hey look
i'd like to come see the apartment and
they were like before they're like well
are you qualified for x x and x and i'm
like um yeah i think so like chill like
they're so it's like so like something
about my name maybe doesn't give off
like good vibes wow they're like well we
can't let you into the apartment unless
we know that you have x and a and i'm
like
okay [ __ ] nasty snot yeah i i got it
[ __ ] okay so [ __ ] rude it's that off
to a good foot
no it's like i'm taking it personal wow
okay why else are you a different person
well you've successfully moved and your
apartment is so nice i've successfully
moved i still
have so much like unpacking and
organizing to do my apartment is so nice
but it has
significantly less closet space like for
my personal club wardrobe
i think half like i'm not even joking
and so i
am being rude like relentless about
just donations and cleaning out my
closet like i literally
have removed like so many iconic pieces
that i never thought i would get rid of
just because like
of the memories like if you saw if you
saw some of the things you would know
exactly what it's from and you would be
like wow you're really gonna do that
that's crazy
crazy so this weekend will be very
transformative as i continue to
build out the space um second thing i'm
gonna save the best for last second
thing
i finally set up my new phone and it
really has just
it's putting like when you set up a new
phone like you feel like a new person
okay so like remember back in the day
when you would like get a new blackberry
and like you had a new pin and everyone
was adding like
ibm and you just felt like you woke up
every morning with so many notifications
more than usual because like everyone
was just like adding you and like
redoing
all the things and you felt like so
popular and special oh no i feel like
that's not what it is for me but i'm
sorry i really just like exposed myself
i'm so glad you had that experience
for me it's like i feel like your phone
is so much a part of like your habit in
your daily
life and i got a phone that's a new size
so now with this bigger phone i feel
like the way i'm holding it like
i feel like a new person like i feel
like you haven't seen someone else yeah
so it's just like on my new phone last
night setting it up just like
feelings there's that new phone vibe
that's just inexplicable i couldn't
agree more but apparently there's this
new
update you know it used to be you got a
new phone you have to download all your
apps make a new background i was like
you know what when i
get my new phone right now my background
was theo and i was like i'll update my
background it's like bruno or something
like that wow that's so rude
but with the new phone update your whole
phone even the way you organize your
apps
transfers to your news fabulous your
background screen transfer is fabulous
so theo lives to see another day and i
love having theo as my background screen
because he's
he's my number one he always will be
like that number one guy
speaking of old photos um i saw my
friend jason last night who's like one
of my oldest friends from high school
and that's why i couldn't watch southern
charm because like i had a couple drinks
and
jason has literally his camera roll
goes back to 2010. whoa how crazy is
that so that's like
my last two years of high school and we
went to college together too so i'm like
i literally spent the entire night last
night like in 2011. it was crazy like
that is crazy
i guess he had an iphone in high school
i had a blackberry i don't remember but
like i don't know how much
[ __ ] how much his storage plan is per
year because like it's a crazy amount of
photos
but it was really like traveling back in
time how many photos do you have on your
phone
55 000 how many do i have it's it's
insane
i mean i have so many screenshots just
from like running six thousand
wow yeah just from like running all you
know our businesses like in our
instagram accounts
every time i take a photo like i take 20
and they don't really delete the old
ones because you just never know when
you're gonna need it
yeah so that's that and then the third
piece of news personal news that i think
might be the biggest out of them this
should have been a fast five story it's
like such big news
it's such big news i know it really
should have but no one wrote it up
unfortunately
um i have changed my instagram handle
from jackie o problems to jackie ashrae
now let's talk about the genesis how did
we get started who is jackie o'problems
what is jackie o problems what are your
problems
okay so i started jackie o problems in
2011 i think
i started on twitter and that was my
handle since 2011 and then
it was my instagram handle snapchat you
know anywhere i went
so didn't me and my problems and it
started as like a play on obviously like
white girl problems and all those
problems right there was a trend
on twitter like in the early 2000s where
you would make like tall girl problems
and it was just like the problems that
tall girls face and yes you were doing
jackie o problems
they were like problems that were
specific to me and it made a lot of
sense at the time
and i never really like thought much
about it in the past few years but every
time i would realize that that's my
instagram handle like i would kind of
cringe because it's like an old-school
internet trend yeah it's like first of
all
it completely dates me like it's like hi
i've been on the internet since 2010
like when and
like i've been here for 10 years and
it's
not like in fashion anymore no and it's
also not what you post like that's at
the end of the day like
you don't post your problems no but also
it's like if it was an
old joke that people were still like
doing
maybe i would have kept it but it's it's
not in anymore
yeah so when i would take the time to
like think about the fact that that was
my handle like i was just like i don't
want this to be my handle anymore
and it would probably happen like once a
year where i realized like oh my god
so and you would try to secure other
handles now we try to secure out their
handle so i
literally this time last year it was
thanksgiving i messaged there's
someone has the handle at jackie o which
is my dream handle and it belongs to a
girl and i messaged her and we were
communicating a little bit but it just
didn't work out in terms of me getting
it from her well
she just she tried to haggle you no she
i mean she just expected a price that i
just wasn't willing to pay for an
internet handle like i do have my limits
yes i know it was
like and so i had to let that dream go
and then you know
a calendar year passed and i realized
again that my handle is jackie o
problems and i was like okay
it is time i need to think of something
else and i was like maybe it should just
be jackie ashrae like i like her
she's a nice girl and so i went to
change it but apparently if you're like
a public figure
and you have a lot of followers you
can't change your handle on your own you
need to get like a contact at instagram
so i went about getting a contact on
instagram and they said they would work
on it
and then yesterday i guess they worked
on it and my handle was jackie ashley
well they didn't even ask you like are
you sure like no yep it just
flipped the switch and i was just like
obviously on the most transitional day
period and i feel so good about it i
know there are some people who are just
like
averse to change and like they're you
know they love it's a big
they're always going to be against it
like no or like just any sort of rebrand
it takes a while to get used to but you
guys i'm telling you
this is for the best it's the right
decision all of
the better vibes that are going to come
from this new handle
and i'm actually someone i love change
like i
like all the time like even moving
apartments like i'm i really embrace
change
and so i'm just so excited about this
this change i really am i'm excited for
you we congratulate
you here at the morning toast good luck
on this new journey and no looking back
no looking back and obviously like i
didn't share with anyone like you know
what i was
when i was thinking about it because i
don't like to talk about things until
they're done
otherwise i feel like i'm going to jinx
them like my instagram handle would have
like
disappeared no my instagram contact
sorry would have you know stopped
working at the company or something
totally because that's something that
would happen to us and then i would have
been stuck with jackie o problem so you
guys would have known how much i hated
this
oh my god totally um okay well i'm so
glad i have a brand new co-host it's
like you have a brand new list and i
feel like that's where why i'm wearing
like all
white you're pure you're like getting
baptized getting
baptized on um i'm freaking out on the
sunshine network i'm free of all my
problems and i just want to say
like even though i've dropped the
problems like it doesn't mean i don't
have problems anymore nobody has more
problems than you nobody has more
problems than me someone was like
i'm gonna manifest having less problems
by putting the name problems in my name
and then taking it out you know you are
literally significantly less problematic
today than you were yesterday
and we absolutely love to see that we
love to see growth we love it
so i'm really excited and make sure to
follow me at jackie ashrae
um so i do believe that it might be time
why you're just gonna rush me right in
huh no i mean like
to be honest like we've been talking
about you for a while like it's hard for
me i knew today i was going to fight big
thing
no it's hard like i just think i think
it's time to move on
do you have anything that you want to
share no i did absolutely nothing
yesterday except be like a disgusting
piece of [ __ ] and like not wash my hair
but you went out to dinner yes i did i
hit the town and the town hit me back i
threw margaritas at dinner and it was
nice
saw my friend jason which was also
really nice um
and yeah i wish i had more to report on
i i just don't life is so uninteresting
for me like
you do you wish you had a life changing
instagram handle change no i wish that
like no everyone around me is like
olivia is a mom she has a new apartment
you have a new apartment you have a new
dog maro has a new dog
and the new dog in the new handle and
the new phone and like ben's parents
just move like everyone has all these
like exciting life updates and i'm just
like still the same disgusting piece of
[ __ ] i was six months ago
so i'm like jealous of everyone's like
metaphor metamorphoses
yeah i'm just not currently experiencing
when i'm still in my cocoon maybe you
should get a new phone
i don't need one like my phone works
very well and it's the 11.
like something about getting the 11
getting the 12 when you have the 11
seems so wasteful to me like me i'll get
the 13. do you know what i mean
you're on odd phone oh that's true maybe
i should get on even so i just feel like
that's that's what apple wants you to do
and like i won't give in to that no i
totally agree with that but it's also
based on like two-year plans like
they come out with a new phone every
year you have a two-year plan means that
you're missing one of every phone
yeah every phone right which you should
that makes sense and
it's like when apple like okay they
decided this year like they're done with
usbs
like no i'm not getting rid of my usb
i'm buying a janky ass converter on
amazon and i'm still using it like
i refuse to give into apple and they're
[ __ ] corporate supremacy like it's
insane
it's insane what if you got a haircut
like a crazy haircut i won't get a
haircut but i actually need a
i'm in need of like a chop just like a
fresh two to three inch trim
that would make me feel good i saw a
photo of myself yesterday that made me
realize like
i need a haircut i feel like if someone
who used to have the short hair it's
like i just
i revel in all of my hair growth but
like
it's too long now you're getting to the
woodstock stage
yes i am and it's i've been there i
actually was stuck in the woodstock
stage for so long thinking that it was
like so cool and now i look back and it
looks so
dirty like someone should have given me
a bath like so sick
um because i'm into long hair but there
is a point where long hair becomes like
circus freak and
the line is very thin so you got to be
careful i saw a picture of myself
yesterday plus like with my white outfit
like i look like it could be nicole
yeah 100 and they haven't let you out of
your bunker in six years and that's why
your hair is so long
yeah exactly okay i'm trying to think of
other things that you could do to like
revitalize no i'm just like really set
on moving
i would l i love that and i and i love
your apartment so much and i understand
why you've been so um resistant yeah
trying to hold back a sneeze sorry are
you trying to cry because you love my
apartment so much i do and it's been so
good to you
no no the thing is is like i would and i
feel like maybe this is like a bad way
to live your life because at the end of
the day like i really do like my
apartment and there obviously there are
things i don't like about it compared to
others
right and so like i feel like moving
just to like keep up with other people
is like a really bad omen like and a bad
way to live your life
yeah when it's like you're happy with
where you're at and why can't you just
accept that
why can't that be enough i am shallow in
vain and now
i technically have the worst apartment
in the family except for margaret that
was a rhetorical question
because i'm the one here advocating for
you to move
just to have like a little bit of spice
in your life no i know like it's like
that tick tock sound like let me um
add a little bit of spice like that's
literally what i need my life is just
like so vanilla right now
i understand well at least you know that
if you move you can use roadway you can
use code jackie 10.
10 off local moves 5 off long distance
all right let's dive right in
okay wow go for it now you're done do
what you got to do now you're good and
ready
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning toes
and just like yesterday today's episode
is brought to you by bruce which i
literally used this morning and last
night the most fabulous brush
brush out there what does bruce you ask
it's the best electric toothbrush on the
market why because it actually works and
it doesn't cost an insane amount of
money
and it's very beautiful um it is very
gorgeous to me how you put it on your
mantel it's just like this little
magnetic not mantle counter
it's like this magnetic little charger
that's very sleek very chic the brush
comes in a few colors jackie and i both
have the
would you say i would say toasty pink is
the shade toast yeah it's almost the
color of this couch
you should bring them they should be
little on the show because they really
match our set yeah
um bruce cleans your teeth at 31 000
movements a minute
manual toothbrushes tap out at just 300.
many electric toothbrushes are barely a
step up for manual
some can do a good job but they cost 200
or more
bruce delivers premier sonic wave
technology without the the markup that
big electric toothbrushes tack on
the brush kit that jackie and i both got
it includes the bruce electric
toothbrush
plus three brush heads magnetic charging
station
and a sleek travel case so you can
travel with your brush and it's a
fabulous way to pack it
sometimes just um throwing like your
toothbrush into your suitcase is like
really unsanitary and gross
um so the brush kit is everything you
need at home and while you're away
and if you want to get 15 off your brush
when you you can do that when you use
promo code toast
at bruce.com again you can try it 90
days risk free
and get a two year warranty at bruce.com
spelled b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com promo code toast bruce dot com
so it's brush with two use
bruce.com promo code toast for the best
electric toothbrush
on the market and the most plenty steeny
and everything of the sort
everything of the sort okay first story
cardi b
says she's too shy to ask male rappers
to collaborate
this is like such a relatable story no i
read this and i was like oh my god like
that would that's me as a rapper like
i'm so
like shy especially around boys like i
feel like i haven't changed at all since
high school and like i feel this
to myself totally cardi b may known for
her brains and lyrics but the rapper
insists she's actually
actually so shy that she can't bring
herself to ask male rappers to
collaborate with her
cardi b revealed in a new billboard
interview she said quote the thing is
i'm shy and really shy to reach out to
male artists to be honest with you
that's why a lot of collabs that i want
i haven't got yet because i'm scared to
reach out
i always get a little star struck i'll
be thinking i'm corny even though i'm
funny
oh that is so cute i mean i feel like in
hollywood a lot of collaborations
happen like through people's teams like
she could have her team reach out that's
the point in having a team you know
yeah but maybe if it's like a really big
artist like it means so much more artist
to artist
100 that i agree with as well so this is
a predicament and one in which i'm
surprised we haven't heard about from
like other
people in music because like this would
literally be us
as rappers like shy
like oh i don't know like you want to
sing with me like yeah it's
awkward to ask too and i kind of i feel
like
maybe cardi b doesn't feel this way but
like i hate asking people for like
stuff because i hate like coming off
desperate do you know what i mean
yeah no i just hate so there's so many
elements to why you would be shy also
when you're
asking people for stuff and i even kind
of feel this way about this is what like
kind of taylor swift was saying about
like wanting to work with bonnie there
but like never thinking
that she could like but you just think
someone's gonna say no so you're
better not asked because they're gonna
say no well that's like everyone's like
fear of rejection always yes
yeah because that's like i feel like
these
sort of insecurities like are all
stemmed from like high school
and those are they like never leave you
like fear of rejection like nervous
talking to boys like
they never leave you for sure but like
not everyone suffers from these
insecurities you know because some
people are just like so brazen
i know and part of me is jealous of
people who are just like so
sure of themselves and so like secure in
who they are who like can just do
whatever they want
and then part of me is also like calm
down yeah no i feel like in
instances like that it's like i'm
jealous of the person who is sure about
themselves and like you know
asks for what they want but then in
other elements of life like you see that
person in a different scenario like at a
restaurant and it's like oh no
oh thank you there is nothing more
frightening than a person who is so
sure of themselves in a restaurant oh my
god
i whenever i'm at a restaurant and i
hear the white people talk like it makes
me want to vomit like it's so
sick certain restaurants just like have
the worst customers do you know what i
mean yeah
no so i feel like that person is
definitely getting great collabs but
like
do you want to be around them at any
other time no especially a restaurant
right absolutely not right that's a
really good point thanks
so um cardi i hope some like pop like
the biggest rappers
male rappers in the game like hear this
interview and reach out to her and
they're like
because i would love to work with you if
you think about it i don't know that
many uh
collabs cardi b has with male artists
especially rappers like she did maroon 5
they're not in the rap scene
and i don't know any other male artist
that she's collaborating but she's
clubbed with like a lot of females and i
guess it's because
she just feels more comfortable asking
which i actually think is very cool
of cardi b like for being a female
rapper who lifts up other female rappers
right and i think that this sort of
what she would consider like a hindrance
of not being able to ask
male rappers it actually winds up being
even more beautiful because she probably
gravitates towards female rappers and
the content that they create together
is amazing yeah like it's just been more
beneficial for her
and she's now at least i don't know if
she did it on purpose to me she is known
as like a female rapper who lifts up
other female rappers when i feel like
for a while
when like nicki minaj was like the
reigning queen of um
rap female rap it wasn't like that at
all it was like very competitive and
that's why like her
and cardi like butted head so much and
now i feel like cardi's like setting
a new standard for like the new wave of
young megan stallions like
young female artists yeah we love to see
it we do
wow speaking of big music news though
bmn
bmn let me take a sip of my diet coke
that's yep
that's kind of big to swallow radio
disney is shitty
devastating radio disney is shutting
down amid a restructuring
disney is shuttering its radio disney
division among the ongoing restructuring
at the media giant
radio disney and radio disney country
will both stop broadcasting in the first
quarter of 2021
resulting in layoffs for 36 full and
part-time employees that cuts deep
that cuts deep i didn't forgot about
radio disney games
it feels like personal this feels like
the last day of camp like
yeah because you want to know why i feel
like
when i think of what was most
influential to me as like a young
burgeoning woman i always i think the
disney channel was so integral in
you know the monster that i became yeah
and i feel like we really grew up in the
golden age of disney but i feel like
every you know older person feels like
they grew up in the golden age but i
actually i think that this is proof
actually that we did grow up in the
golden age of disney channel
the hannah montana that's our raven even
steven's era yes and i think that that
is objectively the golden age of disney
i think disney is still
very cool and they have a lot like you
know descendants i absolutely love
door and stan but it's
it's not hannah montana it's not
comparable it's not wizards of waverly
place no it's not the evan stevens movie
model model
uh double take all those movies dcom
smart houses like
mcguire movie high school musical and
you want to know how you know that it's
not those things because
descendants 3 wasn't in theaters high
school musical right was lizzie mcguire
movie was hannah montana movie was
right that's true like they really
elevated out of their own bubble and
like it was really world domination or
maybe someone at the theater saw
descendants three like was ready to put
it in theaters and then was like oh no
this is so bad
it was a terrible it was the worst of
the franchise which never happens on the
third
no that's what we got because the second
was so good yeah so good
it was an interesting dynamic between
the three films
so yeah so i just feel like as much as i
sound like an old person being like oh i
grew up in the golden age of disney
channel
i feel like radio disney's shutting down
right now is just further proof that i'm
actually not
just an old person like it's 100 true
yeah
yeah i think it's it's really a sad
story end of an era for sure
end of an era for sure but at the same
time i i actually
from a business perspective i see what
is radio disney beneficial for now like
yes disney has good
programming with like decent music but
the disney
genre in terms of music when we were
kids was like a full-blown genre they
needed
their own station yes they don't need it
now but it's a sign of the times like
the way that people are listening to
music
is different i think radio in general is
suffering different so i feel like they
could have pivoted to some sort of like
streaming successful streaming
situation um but i do think it's got
become a little irrelevant yeah it's
just like for every person like over the
age of 21 like today's a sad day we are
mourning the loss of radio disney
i think everyone can think of a memory
in their childhood where they're like
sitting in the back of the car like
maybe
in a car seat just like jamming out to
something on radio disney and everyone
can like recall what station it was like
in their
local area you know in their region yeah
devastating devastating for the whole
disney family
it really is so we'll miss you
yeah i miss you
i miss your smile and i still shed a
tear
every once in a while and even though
it's different
now you're still here somehow
my heart won't let you go and i need you
to know
wow i miss you
[Music]
i miss you literally can't remember a
person's name when they tell it to me
five seconds
before but i can remember a song i
haven't heard since i was in the seventh
grade and that's on being
i'm having your priorities in order like
literally haven't heard that song can't
even remember the last time i heard it
but
could sing it in my sleep didn't even
like wince at one of the words
totally no and that's like not even
hannah's most popular song like that was
like a really random hannah song no
obviously it was like a bad hannah
a banner song there were so many good
ones like i could literally do a full
in-depth like patreon episode on the
discography of hannah montana i'm like
100
because she really went through so many
phases and i feel like the one that i
loved the most was definitely like
hannah montana forever she was making
such good music smooth talking
so rockin he's got everything that a
girl's wanting
guitar cutie he plays a groovy
like that song was so good and that era
where she was like going between like
jake and jesse like she got her hair
yes she did she did cover haircut and
she moved out of the malibu beach house
into like a malibu ranch house with a
horse
and that was an iconic that was an
iconic season yeah and lily moved in
with her which was like a little
question which was just kind of like
moochie
and it's like where were lily's parents
like i know they were okay with like
lily living with um
miley but like that's just like an
insane thing to do like
leave your home and like live with your
friend in high school like if we're
talking about real kids in high school
yeah no totally we should do a whole
patreon episode about it in the new year
because we have like so many episodes to
do
this month like i mean i would love to
get my home
so many people are asking for a home
tour i'm obviously going to do a home
tour on patreon
hopefully this month maybe next month
like because i need i want it to be like
stunning for you guys
um we need to do a holiday gift guide i
have like so many gift ideas that i
would love to share with the group
really i don't have any ideas like i
feel like i'm the worst gift giver
no but like think of the things in your
life that you cherish and value most
theo okay i'll get everyone dogs right
and then also like end of year roundup
best of worst stuff eoi roundup you love
to see an eoi roundup we really do
so i think it's time to get into the
third story which is brought to you by
new x the most fabulous cbd company and
i've been on the cbd train
i feel like it's been a while now maybe
like a year and a half and i really love
cbd gummies that's like my favorite way
to
inhale because i just love snacks and
new x makes a fabulous gummy amongst
other products but their gummies are my
favorite because
they are great tasting they have 15
milligrams of broad spectrum cbd per
gummy
they are vegan and made with all natural
ingredients no artificial flavors colors
or sweeteners
they are thc free thc free and they are
usa grown
hemp lab tested and they're very
affordable for under 10 dollars so new
x's mission is to provide their
customers with the highest quality
products at a reasonable price
with years of experience in sourcing
manufacturing and developing
their goal is to make cbd accessible to
the masses they never sacrifice quality
and all of their products are natural
pure and tested so if you're looking to
get into cbd i really suggest taking
gummies it's just like an easy way to
get started and it's super fun and
delicious
um and it's great if you want a
consistent dose every time so i've taken
a lot of gummies that it's like
a pack of a bear of it's like gummy
bears and it's really inconsistent in
how much dose is in each gummy so that's
why i really like the new x one
um and it's 9.99 which is very
reasonable but they also have other
products you can check out their website
newex.com which is nu-x
dot com to go purchase some of their
great products and you can use the
discount code toast
for twenty percent off so new x is nu
dash x dot com
you can use the code toast for 20 off
for a limited time they have some great
products and if you're meaning to get
into cbd
or you love cbd new x is a company that
i really like and highly suggest
so check it out check it out okay next
story some delicious news
mariah carey launches her own cookie
brand this is interesting
i didn't see this this is so interesting
christmas queen mariah carey has whipped
up her own cookie brand just in time for
the holidays
mariah's cookies is set to launch on
friday december 4th that's today
online offering boxes of a dozen or half
a dozen cookies in 30 major american
markets
for the holiday season the delivery only
brand is selling a holiday hits box
which includes gingerbread white
chocolate cranberry and pumpkin
varieties
other assortments include chocolatey
treats box the pumpkin box and the
gingerbread box
brock's according to a news release once
the yuletide season wraps carrie plans
to offer
other varieties other varieties really
struggling
no i like they're using such big words
for a story about cookies yeah like
chill
relax the baked goods will be available
to order via delivery apps including
grubhub
postmates ubereats and seamless so this
is like a real project for mariah carey
and it's very interesting celebrities do
different things all the time they
create makeup lines skin care lines
they do movies music like i actually
don't i can't recall in recent history
when a celebrity went into like the food
space
there's one celebrity cookie line that
if you think hard enough you'll get
the girl scouts no celebrity cookies
and the celebrities if i give you one
clue you'll get it okay tell me
victoria's secret fashion show what
victoria i don't think of cookies when i
think of the victorian exactly why
what is it carly klaus's cookies she is
a cookie company you don't remember this
they did a victory
i'm sorry is the queen of doing things
that are off brand making a line of
cookies and then her other things
like cookies were like healthy cookies
and at the victoria's secret fashion
show they like
went around backstage like asking all
the models like what they're eating
before the show and everyone's like
carly's cookies okay and as they're like
literally throwing up because they're so
nasty like
oh my that's so funny nobody know that
um i just feel like this is an
interesting
move and not one i expected from like
queen mariah carey sounds so delicious i
literally am going to order some cookies
well that's where you and i disagree
because
i fundamentally have a problem
with cookies that are just like beyond
the regular like chocolate chip
sugar snickerdoodle like there's four or
five major like
cookie categories in terms of flavors
and i just feel like when people go like
off the rails and it's like pumpkin duty
like cookies like
relax like cookies are fine the way that
they are and like people inventing like
new silly like carrot cookies like let's
not
collectively let's just not so these are
bread cookie
okay i'll accept that as a category even
though i don't particularly like it no
it's like that's literally snickerdoodle
yeah so very confusing but we're going
to just call gingerbread for the
holidays sure sure white chocolate
cranberry like actually so unnecessary
so do not okay here ready i'm about to
make a royal decree
keep fruits and vegetables out of
desserts
the two are not meant to be to get there
okay and i just want to say on that note
eat keep them out of desserts and
they're also
not desserts fruit carrots carrot cake
fruit is not a dessert hear ye i agree
if i come over for dinner and you're
like and i got some fruit for dessert
i'm leaving i'm out the door
like i find them to be so hurtful and so
disrespectful like
you know what it's like i totally get it
you're putting out like fresh plates for
dessert and i'm like oh like she's
she made a cake fruit no and i get
people who want to be healthy
and maybe where this is where you just
don't have dessert like let's stop
reinventing yes because it's
disrespectful
to the the whole dessert community like
to put out a carrot cake or a white
cranberry cookie delicious disgusting so
we're gonna disagree like
on some of the finer funds what are her
other categories this
decree um no those oh there's other one
that's a pumpkin varieties cooking sick
disgusting pumpkin is so disgusting and
we all need to collect and i have
something else to say about pumpkin
i never knew this but pumpkin pie is
disgusting
have you had it recently do you think
that i have ever
put a morsel of pumpkin related product
in my mouth
no because i am a woman of taste pumpkin
pie the filling tastes like someone ate
pumpkin chewed it and spit it out
into a pie crust that's literally what
it tastes like and i'm not nearly as
picky as you yeah that's true
no it's like at the end of the day stop
normalizing fruits and vegetables
in our desserts okay even though i'll
make some exceptions
apple pie i'm okay with that blueberry
pie please be okay with it i'm okay with
that too
but i just hold it i'm gonna sneak
carrot cake in their carrot cake it's
not delicious i understand no carrot
cake is it's honestly the cornerstone of
my argument it's like you can't
can you go like elsewhere with your
heart you can't you cannot take
care okay okay so my entire argument is
gonna crumble like carrot cake
if you take carrot cake out so i have to
include okay so this is where we agree
to disagree
yeah and you know what as long as we're
disagreeing like i don't mind like a
little piece of fruit after my ice cream
cake
you know like what yeah like sometimes
at a restaurant like one of my favorite
restaurants in the city like whenever
people are like where should i go to
dinner i always say gemma i think it's
like the best italian food
and i never really get dessert there
even though people love their tiramisu
i'm not crazy about tiramisu
but they do have fresh strawberries and
whipped cream and after like a big heavy
bowl of pasta
it is quite refreshing like i
i hear it you know i see it i i kind of
like it
i can't believe that you did that to me
but it's important to note
eating fruit just like is unacceptable
it's like you have to you can only eat
fruit when you're really full you have
something else to say about fruit
what and it's like there are a few times
in my life when i do happen to eat fruit
and
the occasion calls for fruit maybe like
a summer's afternoon
stop putting different fruits in the
same bowl i
ugly i agree fruit is criminal
i agree and the juices oh it's so sick
sick
sick sick sickening sick no not
sickening
sick also last night zach and i ordered
dinner
we had such a long hard day from the
move so i was just like get the cookies
okay have you ever had the the quarter
pounder cookies from the smith
i don't ever eat at the smithsonian
fundamentally disagree with
their whole uh okay message yeah i can't
as a chain eye we ordered the smith and
we got these big the quarter pounder
cookies they're three
massive cookies and we just sat in our
new living room on the couch we heated
them up and just had warm cookies
that's so nice and it was so nice that
does sound really nice i'm actually like
this conversation is making me
so hungry okay we'll wrap it up are you
ready for our next story
sure it is some sad royal news
srn soil news soil
sr what is it queen elizabeth's dorgy
vulcan dies just two weeks after the
death of william and kate's dog
oh no queen elizabeth has said goodbye
to one of her loving companions theo
cover your ears the 94 year old
monarch's dog
vulcan tied at winston castle do you
ever like sleep weird on your neck and
like you literally can't move your neck
i mean every day
how is theo not crippled like that if
you're watching on youtube
wonder of the universe he sleeps like
that every day on the show and it's like
you're dead you know who else sleeps
like this when given the chance bruno
sweets bruno sweets
maybe it's a cavalier thing maybe they
don't have like a spine or no
maybe they're spineless like braun when
season one
um no maybe like i don't know they just
like the blood draining to their face or
something you know it's like
if i laid that like in that position for
that long i would die because all the
blood would rush to my head
totally sorry to me to interrupt you
vulgate vulcan was a dorky which is a
mix between a corgi
and a dachshund bolden's death leaves
the queen with just one dog another
dorky named candy
cute that's a terrible name for a dog
great name for a stripper
they i think these dogs really had
prominence in
this season of the crown and i just my
heart goes out to her because she
loves her dogs yeah i think one of the
most interesting things about the crown
i mean about the queen that i learned
from the crown was like how important
like just like dog life and dog culture
is to the queen and the monarchy in
general like
part of being a royal is like taking
care of dogs yeah
and that i honestly i feel like the
crown makes being a royal look like
really
unenjoyable and unpleasant but i would
become a royal just to have like a
gaggle of cavaliers right like someone
else like walks
shits grooms and like they just love me
a hundred percent
anyways the queen is well known for her
love of corgis but her last dog of the
breed whisper died in 2018.
so now she has dorkies which are the
combo
like uh yeah i know i like how do you
say that right
there are certain words i will never be
able to spell correctly
okay uh guarantee i have no idea how to
spell it
and there are certain words i will never
be able to pronounce correctly
endowshand is one of them
okay we are hearing uh my producers
telling me my ear it is doc
dachshund is that he says no way no way
it's darshan
dachshund no way oh and by the way let's
just call a speech
jackie let's just call a spade a spade
adoption is a wiener dog like let's just
call it that because that's what it is
okay but what's the kind of dog that
kendall jenner has those like big ones
that
big ones i literally knew you were gonna
say that the ones
i think it's a rottweiler anyone
rottweiler is literally like a guard dog
that could kill you i think that's what
kendall has i saw it on her story last
night but adoption
honestly talking about dog breeds is
giving me ptsd
i just want you guys to know how dark
sunday spells
so that you know why we're pronouncing
it this way
i would have you could have said i'll
give you a billion dollars german
i never would have said dachshunds i
would have went more in germany
[Music]
[Laughter]
spell it for the people spell it for the
people d-a-c-h-n-d-a-c-h-a-dot
s-h-u-n
[Laughter]
oh my god okay so dachshund you truly
learned something new every day from the
morning toast yesterday it was a slack
merger
and today it's dachshund that is the
craziest
news i've ever heard i like new time to
process what are like certain words that
you will like never spell
there are so i have a few words and even
my autocorrect is like what are you
trying to spell because
you know ben like literally can
for the life of him cannot spell
opportunity right he spells it opp
e-r-t-u-i-n-n-i-t-y and you know what
word i can spell
whatever is like physical psychic
i can't spell any of those words that
are like p-h-y-c
right yeah yeah ever i really cannot
spell guarantee like
i i'm always like guarantee like i just
cannot figure out
[Laughter]
why didn't you just scream at me like
you scared the [ __ ] out of me like
you're like
you know oh auntie nobody jackie
you know how anti-culture thrills me no
i know like you just feel it
theo's unfazed neck broken neck snapped
like
that was funny oh well now you'll
remember how to spell it
yes i will guarantee fifth and final
story wow a little
pet biz news pbn are you ready for it
yes ma'am petco has filed to go public
as consumers adopt more pets during the
pandemic wow
so that's just like big dog pet news
yeah they will be publicly they want to
be publicly traded again this time on
nasdaq
with the ticker you know what the ticker
is like they're um the button
no the letters that they're going to use
so like if they were publicly be tmt
of course their ticker is going to be
p-u-p
well no i guess they sell other pets
besides dogs w-o-o-f
woof oh my god that's so oh sorry theo i
didn't mean to wake you up
um that is so cute but you know what
maybe this is gonna be like crazy
something about like mass
commercial businesses like around pets
like gives me a pit like
i just don't want to know what the hell
what they do to the pets at head coach
honestly i was at a petco like very
recently
and um it was a little pit induced you
know what i mean
and it's like they say petco where the
pets go but it sounds more like petco
where the pets get treated poorly like
i just have a bad feeling about it you
know but this is not based on any proof
i feel like because when there's when
there's so many businesses like petco is
so successful there's probably hundreds
of stores
and you're bound to have like at least
one and
you know maximum like a lot right of
employees who are
not kind towards animals right no then
it's just like a quality control problem
on behalf of petco i just and i'm not
saying you know it's better than
i'm just i'm not i don't really proof
i'm just i get weird vibes from like
mass
market mass commercial businesses about
pets
i hear what you're saying i'm much more
of a boutique like yeah
small business yeah because they like
care about their pets where it's like
pickles
you know they just care about the bottom
line yeah but i think the person who
started it like must have cared about
pets to like
devote their whole life yeah to the pet
industry
ah we've been to a petco only once
there's like no actually there's one in
the city it's really far
is it yeah i just buy everything online
like if you like whoever's
invented chewy is an absolute genius
chewy
chewy first of all the name is so cute
second of all it's just like amazon
exclusively for pets and they have like
just as good of shipping as amazon
and like they have just as good of like
data remembrance so it's like i don't
need to put my address in
again yeah and my billing and my
shipping and my credit card and they
work with your vet so it's like if you
need certain like meds or like theo's
was on a food for a while that was like
pet prescribe vet prescribed
it's just like a fabulous product yeah
very good
are they public chewy for sure you think
i feel like if pecos not
chewy is like newer yeah but chewie's
digital like digital moves fast
chewy the online business for petsmart
that went public more than a year ago
yes thank you
has seen its share rise more than 150
percent so far this year to a market
value of 30.3
billion i feel like this is a good like
investment
yeah i feel like on my robin hood um
this is not an ad segue
i just do actually use robinhood i feel
like i should buy some shares of chewy
you should and chewie's ticker is
c-h-w-i
less cute than one w-i or y c-h-w-i
oh okay less cute than woof way less
cute always cute though still oh it's
cute
okay those are the fast five stories and
i do feel as though in some way shape or
form you needed to know
each one of them okay and i'm really
excited because while we don't have a tv
recap segment today we do have a kelly's
mindless news and it is so mind-blowing
like it may be one of the worst offenses
yet
um and our kelly kelly's mindless news
segment is brought to you by frame
bridge
making it easier and more affordable
than ever to frame your favorite things
without ever leaving your house from art
prints and posters to the photos sitting
on your phone you can frame bridge just
about
anything frame bridge is the perfect way
to give easy and thoughtful gifts in
just minutes you can turn a photo from
your phone
into one of the best gifts ever here's
how it works just go to framebridge.com
and upload your photo or they'll send
you a package
to safely mail in your physical pieces
preview your items online in dozens of
frame styles and gallery wall layouts
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers
the experts at frame bridge will custom
frame your item and deliver your
finished piece
straight to you or anyone on your list a
handcrafted personalized gift from
framebridge starts at 39
and all shipping is free plus our
listeners will get 15
off their first order at framebridge.com
when you use code
toast i have a few pieces in my house at
our frame bridge and i also have
a few pieces that i've like
traditionally framed and my god is it so
much easier going to frame bridge like
the framing industry before frame range
is so archaic and
so expensive the fact that frame bridge
exists and you could literally like
upload stuff from your phone because
where are your best pictures um on your
phone
to go digitally print them did you see
my instagram story yesterday where i put
that photo of me and i was gonna hang it
front and center in my living room
that frame is from frame bridge oh wow
that's such a nice frame yeah and it's
stunning
so you can get started today frame your
photos or some send someone the perfect
gift
go to framebridge.com and use the promo
code toast to save an additional 15 off
your first order
just go to framebridge.com the promo
code is toast again that's
framebridge.com
promo code toast so i'm this little guy
look at the little guy crunchy man
i'm particularly excited about today's
episode today's segment of
kelly's mindless news like the 4th of
july
because of course it is from hello
magazine like the number one offender of
kelly ripa
and her mindlessness and her
mindlessness so here is the
headline okay kelly ripa's stunning
beach photo with mark consuelos is
couple
goals okay kelly ripa and mark consuelos
love a beach getawa getaway and while
they can't currently jet off for a
romantic vacation
they can still reminisce about one so
just the mere concept that one of kelly
ripa's like throwback thursday's post is
getting written up is so absurd but
okay sure you would think like if it's
getting written up it must be something
sensational of course
the live with kelly and ryan host shared
a throwback photo with her shirtless
husband on instagram stories on thursday
oh it's not even a photo post it was a
story her instagram story is getting
written up
the live with kelly and ryan host shared
a throwback photo with her shirtless
husband on instagram stories on thursday
as she counted down the days until she'd
see him next in the loved-up selfie
kelly is snuggled up behind mark and
they are smiling for the camera
so what do you think what do you think
we're going to get we're being described
as a stunning beach photo okay i'm gonna
say
kelly and mark like maybe in the 80s or
the 90s together on the beach
like a couple cute couple goals photo
like nothing crazy
okay ready i'm literally scared
[Laughter]
obviously this will be posted on our
instagram so you can go check it out for
reference
it is a blurry zoomed you wouldn't even
know they're on the beach except
i thought it was like obviously a third
party took the photo there's a beach
behind them they're standing in front of
the waves like a beach pic
they're really it's not that
revolutionary but like that's what you
described
i really feel like we're on to something
hello magazine is really um
they're the number one offender of
mindlessness yeah
that is so crazy it never ceases to
amaze honestly like just when you think
it can't get worse
bam okay bam there it is it's so
mindless and it's so
it's such an like that's your modern day
journalism how does that make you feel
as someone who
briefly studied journalism in college um
it makes me feel like
deeply sad for like the state of the
world yep and that's where we're at you
guys that's the mindlessness that you
definitely needed to know yeah before
you jet off into the weekend you have
any big weekend plans well i'm just
going to continue
to organize my apartment i have so much
like
house stuff to do i have a lot of
organizing and going through my
closets and just figuring out where
things are going to go and i'm
so looking forward to being done with
that and then enjoying my new pad
yeah that's exciting like again super
happy and jealous that like you have
this like big new journey ahead of you
yeah what about you i have absolutely no
plans just gonna you know probably do
what i do every day and like watch a lot
of tv
maybe we should go to dinner or
something oh my god i would love to i'd
love to take you to this new restaurant
i've been telling you about
tomorrow night sure fabulous let's do it
fabulous that's good that's fabulous
family this is fabulous
fabulous is like a word that i've been
reintroduced to like maybe
a year ago from margot because she like
said it once and i never
like forgot it and it's such a fabulous
word it is
and it makes you like only like
older mature stunning fabulous women use
it you know you say when you were in
high school no
only women of like elevated like
elegance use it
yeah and i want to be that i want to be
elevated elegance yes exactly
so you guys thanks for a great week of
shows we hope you enjoyed all the
content being put out
today yesterday the day before every day
if you're looking for more content maybe
it's time for you to become a patreon
member
patreon is our subscription service so
if you're new here you don't know what
our patreon is that we're always talking
about
this show is totally free but if you're
looking to get some more content from us
we release five extra episodes a month
on our patreon channel for 7.99
those five episodes are vlogs they're
podcast episodes
videos featuring husbands sisters it's a
little bit more in-depth tours
yes a little bit more in depth um more
behind the scenes you know we're behind
a paywall we get a little crazy over
there
um and if you sign up now you get access
to all of our old episodes so we've been
doing five a month for like the last two
years so it's over 200 episodes
it's a great um thing to uh do if you're
looking for more content and you want to
support the show so patreon.com
the morning toast is the website to use
for that and thanks for the continued
support thanks for watching this week we
hope you had an amazing
week and have a good weekend stay safe
stay smart be be cool don't drink and
drive
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the monday morning show
where we deliver the fast five stories
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so you're watching us
on youtube please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public video i heard
everybody catch box all the places where
we listen to podcasts find out some more
nachos leave a five star review about
how beautiful
stunning and smart truckers for tmt
coming out to play what's good
hope you guys have an amazing weekend
we'll see you on monday
bye bye follow me on instagram goodbye
you